[Music] It's a
report.
The results of the special exam for first
-year students on a
remote island are
out.  When you choose a path
[music]
Are all human actions
determined by goals?
The words returned by the stone to my brain today and the
transformation called common sense Weave the brand name into a young wife Then
you're playing the role of a genius You're not there, you're
bound to continue
I
wonder which goddess will laugh at the end
[music] The
ambiguous
time
Drying my throat
Before the outline was defined, it seemed to be covered In the
recklessness that calls the above hardships a dream, the
light
shook off the annoying wind
and warned against strength
[music]
was always
It feels like summer vacation is finally here
[Music]
Mr.
Horikita, can't you see what you're doing?
I'm planning to join
you for dinner, but
please
refrain from doing
so.  I
found a delicious teppanyaki restaurant I
will contact all the students The
special exam will start soon The
school has sent an email to all students Please
check your mobile phone and
follow the instructions
Special exam  Please gather in
your designated room at the
designated time. If you are
more than 10 minutes late,
you may be penalized
. Please gather in Room 504 by
6pm today.
One of the remaining two chairs is Mr.
Ayanokoji.
[music]
slightly off  Without further ado, here
's an explanation of the special test.In
this test,
we're divided into eight groups that are likened to the planets of the solar system
, and tests are conducted within
each group.The groups are made up of several people from each class, with a
total of 14
A class members.  3 people from
class B is also
Kyoko Tsuji, so we
will not act as class D, but as this group
Mars.
On the 1st,
at 8:00 am tomorrow morning,
an email from the school will be sent to the
group. Twice a day, we will have
discussions within the group
to find out who is the winner.
E-mail to the school
Only one
response per person However, there is no right to
reply to the
courtesy person himself.  500,000 private points will be paid to all members of
the
courtesy courtesy recipients will receive an
additional 500,000
of
500,000.
500,000 private points will be paid
to the reward recipient. As a result,
if the reward recipient himself completely conceals his identity
, only the reward recipient
will receive 500,000 points.
3rd 4th result will newly appear by
exposing preferential winners as soon as
possible What about the following two
results?  If
someone other than the privileged student sends an email to the school without waiting for the end of the exam and
answers correctly,
the student who answered will get 50 class
points, and the
correct answer will get 500,000 private points at
this point.  The group test ends If the
same classmate as the honoree answers correctly, the
answer is invalid The
test continues
Result 4 If
someone other than the honoree sends an email to the school without waiting for the end of the death penalty
If the
answer is incorrect The student made a mistake
class will lose 50 class points, and the
recipient will receive 500,000 private points.
At the same time as receiving the
award, the class to which the awardee belongs
will receive 50 class points. The
group test will end when the answer is wrong. If the
same classmate as the awardee answers incorrectly, the
answer will be invalid and will not be accepted.
Well,
I'm a little confused about life and life that I don't understand, I
'll explain later, so don't
bother the teacher.
Announcing only the increase or decrease in the points of the
recipients I don't regret the identity of the
recipients.  wins The
traitor finds the patrons And the last one The
traitor misjudges the patrons
Thinking
Analyzing the current situation
, clarifying
the issues, finding the problem-solving process,
imagining
and creating new value If this is the test  Guidance
by imagining how people move It
seems troublesome
[music] It's
about time
Same sentence It
seems that neither of you was selected as a
preferential recipient.  It all depends on how you handle it I
've thought of a way to lead to victory, but as
expected I
'm looking forward to the outcome
It's the weather you're most wary of right now
. Let me sit with you, Suzuna.
Give it to me, how did she get
such a result in the deserted island test
?  No, as a
result of the previous test,
it's not difficult if you know the species, but there
are only a limited number of people who can come up with ideas and implement them in that situation.
Like Ayanokoji-kun
It's
hard to say I'm a cooperator, but this is probably goldfish feces
at most.
Voyeurism. This is a game.
Katsuragi and Ichinose, you
know how strong they are. They
're not my enemies.
No matter how many times I've seen it, it's the worst team.
I can't force myself, but there might be
a microphone set up in this room
. When that
happens,
the people who didn't introduce themselves will be at
a disadvantage.
If
you don't like me being the facilitator,
you can
tell me how
to
proceed.
There may be gaps, but I usually avoid it.It does
n't seem like there are any particular opinions, so I'll
proceed.First of all, if there's something you don't understand
, I think everyone should discuss it.
Clearing the exam with everyone, in other
words
, pursuing result 1 is the best plan.
What do you think
?  Of course,
I'll cooperate as well. What character are
we? All of us, Class A
, will be
silenced. Silence
. Why did I pay too much attention?
It's not to have
Katsuragi's instructions or
to allow a courtesy person who doesn't have a discussion and who doesn't know who to win.
Suspecting someone around you as a
favoritism by putting it away The greatest danger is making mistakes
The usefulness of not talking
However, as long as you don't know where the preferential recipients are, there is a
possibility that the number of points between classes will spread, is
n't it?
I understand Hamaguchi's concerns.Since
I don't know how to distribute the preferential recipients in each group, it's
difficult to execute a silent strategy, but Katsura is
aware of the
mechanism.
It's a rule that the side sticks
to.There should be equal favors
in all classes.It's unlikely to be concentrated in one place.I
don't think you're wrong.
All the first-year students
have complete trust in Class A. It's
easier than looking for a preferential treatment,
isn't it?
Even if
there are hidden disadvantages
, the people in the lower classes will
throw away the limited chances of a comeback.
No, it
's the same as your plan to keep pace, isn't it
? No,
this group consists
of 4 Class D and 4 Class C, and 3 Class
B and 3 Class A. In other words
, if we clear with a result of 1,
Class E and Class C.
You can get an extra 500,000 private points,
right? In
that case, you class B would have
to accept self-sacrifice, otherwise
you might let class A run away.
It's not extreme, and
I'm a distant opinion, so it's a good counterargument.We
had a meeting in advance
Class B
No matter what, Class A's policy wo
n't change.We won't respond to discussions.So,
what's wrong with
Machida and Ichinose
?  I can't even do it
Each class has its own motives
Mr. Karuizawa
Hey,
I have something I want to ask you, but
before summer vacation
I got into a fight
with Rika Huh, who is Rika?
You
're a different person with a dumpling head
I don't remember I don't know
He said that he was rude and that when he was
waiting in line at the cafe, he
interrupted him and pushed him away.
I don't know
about that
.
Hey, don't just take it without permission
What are you doing? What are
you going to do if your phone breaks?
If you
don't like it, what should
I do? It's no good acting like a girl.
Everyone, let's go
Yeah
, I'll ask Rika one more time
Thank you,
Machida-kun
, I agree with the
need for discussion.
It's too much, is
n't it up to you to think about it? In
essence, it's better to replace the surprises for the students
on the uninhabited island.  And mobile phones are free
That's already it, so let's talk more comfortably I
think you'll suffer if you shut yourself in
[music]
You guys are free to enjoy it however you want, but
don't trust it
There might be a favored person in B class Mr.
Machida  You can trust your comrades, of
course
[music]
Joint group of
weaklings Lined up
with dignity and trucks are the worst
Alas, it's not exactly
right Just take a step Welcome
Mud boat
Lunch In
the midst of the commotion
It's like I
'm leaving the vanishing river with my hands,
okay now
[music]
[applause]
Don't be lonely, stop me
Thank you for stopping me
[music]